Tell just take one of those three that you haven't closed and what was one of the objections as to
why they didn't do the deal? Okay so I went to a close with the guy and I told him the price
and I priced out 1500 bucks a month and from right then and there he just had told me that
he was too far out like he was he couldn't do business so right there it was my fault because
I asked him I was like how when could you get an estimate he told me tomorrow like the next
whatever that week and I was like okay I didn't bother to ask him work-wise he was three months
out so that was that was my fault right there I so I should have dug deeper and done a little
better and I think the pricing was a little too high so the guy basically kind of shuttered that
price right yeah that's what it kind of seemed like like it was either yeah that's the price
was just too high as he might like I should have put it lower and he just buckled as soon as I
set 1500 bucks a month so here's the deal and this is a good point and we were talking about
this a couple hours ago when I was in dylan but guys a lot of times they the the business owners
sometimes not a lot of times but sometimes they don't tell you their actual objection
right so what did this guy do he he dylan dropped price and he shit his pants and instead of saying
oh that's too expensive what did he do he said oh I'm too busy right not to mention he's paying
for was it home advisor yeah he's paying for home advice okay paying for home advisor hasn't ever
said a damn word about being too busy he's not allergic to money so he's lying through his teeth
the real reason isn't because he's backed out bro the real reason is because you fucking scared him
with price which I love because you're pricing correctly but here's the deal the the only way
that you're going to overcome that because it should sting that's that's fine okay the only
thing I would say is the way you're going to make that not happen in the future is on your pre-closed
screencast you need to make sure to emphasize how much value they're going to be getting from
these leads without overselling it right so you're on the calculator you're going to show them hey
like dude look man at five thousand dollars and 30 or let's see 15 leads and 30 profit 30 percent
close you're going to make six thousand dollars of profit twenty thousand dollars of net of gross
revenue like that's insane that's from 15 and like what if I get you 30 so the key is dude you just
need to build more value on when you're doing the screencast so that when you get on you're just
going to like you almost need to get them thinking like dude he's going to charge me three grand or
some shit like that yeah right and so one thing you could even drop in dude is you could say you
know how it says six thousand in the bottom right hand corner when you put the stuff in right you
could say something like this you could go what we typically like to do is we like we like to look
at the worst case scenario and we want to make sure we at least double your money right so we want
to make sure so then if he starts doing the math he's like fuck dude he might charge me three grand
a month right because six thousand divided by two so just little things like that but the only way
is you need to build more value I believe on the screencast with the price calculator but also
I think and that comes with me and you communicating is you probably didn't show
enough social proof with some of these other clients that have landed big jobs
and we have a lot of clients that are making a lot of money but anyway that's how I would handle that